aumenta la tensión en el conflicto Rusia
Ucrania este miércoles el presidente
ruso Vladimir Putin supervisó ejercicios
militares ante un posible ataque nuclear
con el lanzamiento de misiles balísticos
el ejército de Moscú realizó pruebas en
la Península de kamchatka y en aguas del
mar dens
comandante jefe supremo de acuerdo con
el plan de preparación de las fuerzas
rusas Bajo su liderazgo se está llevando
a cabo un entrenamiento para el control
de las fuerzas armadas rusas durante el
cual se llevarán a cabo tareas de
ataques nucleares masivos por parte de
las fuerzas de disuasión nuclear en
respuesta a un ataque de enemigo durante
las últimas semanas Rusia ha acusado
repetidamente a Ucrania de estar
planeando el lanzamiento de una bomba
sucia en su contra además de asegurar
que Moscú Busca provocar una respuesta
activa de la comunidad internacional
paralelamente la otan inició ejercicios
neptun strike sobre el Mediterráneo
italiano unas maniobras periódicas que
en esta ocasión se llevan a cabo
mientras la guerra hace estragos en
Ucrania sin corbata con casco y chaleco
el director general de la otan participó
de los ejercicios y aseguró que no son
una escalada del conflicto sino una
forma de disuadir a Rusia
menudo acusa a otros por lo que
pretenden hacer ellos mismos lo hemos
visto en Siria lo vimos al comienzo de
esta guerra en Ucrania y por lo tanto
debemos observar muy de cerca lo que
hace Rusia y deben entenderlos
por primera vez desde mayo el ministro
de defensa ruso se ha comunicado vía
telefónica con sus homólogos de Estados
Unidos Reino Unido y Francia lo cual ha
sido visto con buenos ojos por la otan